no you gotta go on the couch
this feels like the head of the table it
feels right
hi
this shirt oh thanks hi sweetie hi
I had an unreal nougat like a fake uh
Snickers it was great I wasn't delicious
oh Mike's got one too
yeah I cut some wires down for you guys
mine's sparkling your guys this is flat
this is gonna be fun that I get to see
you guys because I feel like we haven't
seen each other in days no we've been in
a
deep dark riding hole they're in that
point of the Season that I always love
where a sign pops up on your office door
that says do not disturb okay yeah yeah
I feel it genius at work yeah there was
a time of year where there's not enough
time in a day where you're like
oh my God we got so much to do and then
production meetings are popping up and
people are having questions like is it
is it this jar or is it this jug are
they oh god just pick a jar good job but
then then they do anyway well not that
it can't be that one that ruins the joke
Meg and I are just talking about that I
don't want to do it all but if you don't
do it all yeah everything falls apart
yeah you know you got something in your
head and no one else really knows what's
in your mind that's not their felt that
on your head they're not in your head
you know and plus we cut all the
description from our
script so that we can reach our page
count you know what I mean like you know
like if it comes in 30 pages we're like
I know but cut all the stages directions
yeah
descriptive flowery writing yeah yeah we
cut it all out so that we can reach our
page count not because we the the
network says you got to do it because
we're like okay if we write a 30 page
script we're going to be cutting five
minutes out in the editing room and yeah
that's gonna be me that gets cut because
I'm not the one who wrote it yeah
[Music]
guys Glenn's not here ladies and
gentlemen welcome to the podcast Glenn's
not here
he is going to Alabama for family uh
some family business so we'll just have
to make do oh don't you do it well it'll
be fine yeah the other thing is we were
going to talk about uh the road trip
episode yeah but uh Glenn has very
specific memories he really wants to
share so we'll wait we will wait so just
so I'm 100 clear because I was a part of
this meeting but I didn't break it up at
the time because I didn't want to take
the wind out of Glenn's sails he said
well I'm not going to be here tomorrow
but um you guys definitely need to do
the podcast because we need to get it
out and um also
um you can't do it uh the way that you
want to do it you can't do it the way
the audience wants it which is us just
talking about the episodes you're going
to have to come up with a completely
different format
um and just sort of Riff and then when I
get back before you invited me I didn't
realize
like bringing a comedy ringer let's
let's pump this thing up let's juice
this spot a little bit oh okay let's
juice the pot you can juice a pot pie
you juice anything you want to have more
juice in it that's for sure that's for
sure that I know um why did Glenn why
did Glenn not want us to talk about the
the episode because Glenn and I uh I
think are are credited with writing that
one and uh I I actually have fond
memories of writing that one and and I
guess he does too he really wants to
share those stories and it's good
because my font memories are blurry to
the point of non-existent I just feel as
though I remember something what I
remember may not I don't know I'm hoping
I'm hoping he can pry it out of the egg
here and uh you know and crack you wide
open thank you
well I do have some mailbag questions
that people wrote in yeah just for us
and then also specific questions for
Caitlyn they wanted
[Music]
no I thought of your [__] and balls yeah
thank you thank you thank you yeah I
didn't want to say it yeah
um let's go to the mail Megan let's go
to the mail we should tell people
because I don't think we told them the
reason that we're
in this crappy horrific overhead
fluorescent lighting yes it's because we
can't stop in the middle of the writing
day drive over to our uh podcast office
drive back here and start it's a it
there's two there's no time we just have
too many offices
there's not enough time we need to make
the show listen we gotta go over to the
valley then back to Century City back to
the fox
Megan have you been reading the the
scripts I haven't read your rewrite of
my script last night super funny I loved
it I can't wait to read it
no say insane
I don't understand this style of
marketing to get people I've noticed it
about that's that's how I feel I I don't
think we're making here's why though
okay
oftentimes we change the title in the
editing room all part of the rich
Mastery you say that this is all part of
it it's all part of the rich tapestry of
the production of this television series
and the story yeah I just got all the
episodes
last night I think
in all the episodes
I got all the all the ones that are that
are out ready to be read last night I
haven't started reading them yet can you
describe
my state my emotional state my physical
state what was it two nights ago yeah
yeah what's going on with Robbie I think
this I think this would be good this is
yeah he will he came home door opened
and closed and then just you just heard
slow footsteps
coming in I thought maybe there was an
intruder yeah you don't move slow no I'm
a fast like a cat usually yeah yeah
um no you came home and um you know I I
was making dinner and I came over and
gave you a hug and you're like hi hi and
the smile was not real and then we
hugged and I was like what's going on uh
and then just no information out of you
and you're really forcing it and trying
for the kids because they came and said
hi and get a good dinner and then we
were watching TV and you're just kind of
like staring off to the side not
watching and wouldn't really say much
you're like oh it's just it's just it's
just a lot just a lot of work and then
put on again put on a pretty good show
for the kids for our whole like
nighttime stuff I'm washing my face I
come into the bedroom and he's sitting
we have a little like
you know bench thing at the end of our
bed he's sitting on it
sitting on the back bench just staring
at the ground is that your head was in
your hands I was like what is what is
happening
you're you're like depressed I've never
seen this yeah you were very good what
day was that two days ago two days ago
we've been we've been in a good week
before I get that we had like a really
good run and it wasn't I didn't I wasn't
miserable
um and the reason I feel comfortable
sharing this with our audience is
because
um I don't want anybody to feel sorry
for me I just want them to to know that
I'm trying to give it my all and we all
are we're in season 16 and people think
we're like we put things on like
autopilot and we and we don't we really
want to make something great and so
again I'm not asking for people to feel
sorry for more people have really
difficult jobs that are life and death
and this is not absolutely so so but in
terms of like I I don't want to qualify
it other than other than to say that we
I care so much about doing something
good and it's hard in season 16 to make
sure that if we're only gonna do Eight
Episodes
that they're all really great and I
think everybody feels that way and
everybody has those moments throughout
the season where they're just like
exhausted like physically and
emotionally exhausted well there was the
point you know where we were talking and
I was like I really think we should not
ride on Sunday right because I'm like
we're gonna go
you know 10 11 12 days in a row 8 to 12
hours of writing non-stop
um and I don't mean like kind of like
brainstorm I mean sitting in front of
computer typing yeah you know uh
and you your brain
just drains because you're just pumping
everything you every little
ounce out of it you can you gotta
replenish yeah dude I was staring out
the window
at like three in the morning like I woke
up I had to go to the bathroom and I
woke up and I started looking out the
window and just kind of looking at the
view and then maybe 10 minutes went by
and realized dude you're just staring at
the window like a girl twice go back go
back to back that window right there
tearing two times she's just staring out
the window
it's also good like it's you're in like
your most creative point where you're
pushing yourself out this past Saturday
I had a blast I knew I had to run yeah
and it was raining and I went out to the
to my office and I just spent the day
writing and I had a lot of fun so it's
definitely fun It's just sometimes you
just get drained and I knew that if I my
kids were so sweet my oldest son was
like Dad I can see you're sad and he's
like I'm not used to seeing you sad I
was like I'm not sad I'm just kind of
drained and he goes I got the answer for
you all you have to do is just look at
cat means
just look at cat memes and I was like
all right [__] it so he went to bed to
put them to bed and then I Caitlyn
actually fell asleep and I just couldn't
sleep in my I was like my my head was
spinning and I just took out my phone
and I just Googled cat memes never done
before in my life and I I found it
delightful
when I fell asleep I woke up but I was
excited about coming to work yeah but
I'll tell you what I'm not feeling I'm
feeling jazzed now like it was a
breakthrough week of just you know I
think just kind of
something to the grindstone yeah but
what do you put your nails your ax to
the grindstone did you put your nose to
the grindstone no why the [__] would you
put your nose that's not a good idea
well it acts of the grindstone doesn't
that sharp it happens yeah but but for
whatever reason I think it's no no you
don't have an ax to grind but you put
your nose to the grindstone there you go
yeah
your head's down and you're just crying
you're not up looking around like I'd
love to describe some other things yeah
yeah you know what I mean
you know I'd like to grind that night
over there you're like I like to grind
this Stone and uh with I like to grab my
sword on the stone where does it come
from
um two rival explanations one is that it
comes from the supposed habit of Millers
who checked that the stones used for
grinding cereal weren't overheating by
putting their nose to the stone kissing
a baby's forehead to see if they have a
fever but that's not about working hard
you know that's just like smelling your
words
the other comes from the practice of
knife Grinders when sharpening blades to
bend over the stone or even lie flat on
their fronts with their faces near the
grind so everyone holding the blades
that makes more sense like pay attention
yeah you're just you're in close and
you're going well look it's it was a
good week I filmed really good about
where we are with the scripts we gotta
maybe do that again for a few more days
by the way that day whenever it was
Wednesday was actually a great day it's
just it's it's it's exhausting in a in a
very strange way because you do
something physical then you're tired and
your body is tired and you want to go to
sleep if you're doing something just
mental all day long exhausted you're
just exhausted when you can't go to
sleep I'm gonna I'm gonna say that
probably there's a lot of uh creeps and
listeners out there who um who are maybe
also having a difficult week this week
and maybe uh for the creeps not as much
as for the listeners you guys are [__]
but the creeps if you could throw a cat
meme in just every once in a while
throughout the episode you just maybe
with a transition here and there used to
add a nice cat sound
[Music]
so wait these memes are just still
photos they're not like you say
something funny
if it moves it's a gift but still it's a
meme interestingly enough I think my son
prefers dogs I think he likes dogs more
than cats but he likes cat memes yeah he
well well he likes dog shaming me dog
shammy memes Professor those are fun
you might as well those are good
[Music]
hey all we are supported by athletic
greens we love their green powder ag1
and take it pretty much every day
especially when we're writing the new
season that's right we got a bag in the
kitchen for our morning dose morning
dose one scoop and we're getting 75 high
quality vitamins minerals Whole Foods
sourced superfoods probiotics and
adaptogens it keeps us alert and focused
all day that makes it sound like like
Adderall no it's not it's not Adderall
it's it's the best kind of multivitamin
it contains less than one g of sugar no
GMOs no chemicals and no artificial
anything well less than one gram of
sugar okay how do I get a prescription
for it oh you don't need a prescription
a subscription sure but it's just green
delivered right to your door now see I
used to know a guy in New York who would
do that you know sometimes he had
Adderall too so did I call that guy or
yeah but see this green stuff AIDS
mental Clarity and alertness did his no
no it did not to make it easy athletic
greens is going to give you a free one
year supply of immune supporting vitamin
D D and five free travel packs with your
first purchase all you have to do is
visit athleticgreens.com
sunny again that's athleticgreens.com
Sunny to take ownership over your health
and pick up the ultimate daily
nutritional Insurance
uh hey are you hiring maybe you need to
hire someone to wear many hats at your
company which can be challenging or you
might have a single position that you
need to fill but you can't seem to find
that one candidate who's a great fit for
your brand well look good news Okay
ZipRecruiter can help you find that
person whether you're looking for an
engineer a nurse an accountant or even a
mascot they have mascots on ZipRecruiter
apparently so Megan apparently so should
we hire a mascot what would we do with a
mascot what do we do with a mascot well
now that I'm I'm just thinking there's a
mascot Market out there and we're not
tapping it okay yeah I think we need to
get on over to ZipRecruiter and we gotta
check this out okay they have the
technology that helps you find the top
candidates before inviting them to apply
so you get matches with the right
experience so you get matches with the
right experience you don't want to match
with the wrong experience you want to
match the right experience like you want
people who went to mascot school right
who have their masters and mascots try
it now for free at ziprecruiter.com
Sunny once again that's ziprecruiter.com
Sunny ZipRecruiter the smartest way to
hire
okay well we'll do some mailbag stuff
because I got a bunch of questions and
uh and so we'll take advantage of
Caitlyn being here to answer some of
them uh question first one is from Isaac
um I'd really like to hear the comedic
influences uh for the guys growing up
who made them decide they want to do
comedy in particular I would love to
hear the answer to this question from
Caitlin Meg or Mary Elizabeth so yeah
well you have Caitlyn so yeah you can
hear I'll speak for all of us because
I'm a woman and we all all have the same
definitely Carol Burnett
um Gilda Radner we watched a lot of
Saturday Night Live I thought she was
great Betty White for sure all the
Golden Girls it was a big Golden Girls
fan but Betty White
now all of them Dorothy's deadpan like
straight guys
comedic assassin yeah totally uh all of
them that the that show was a huge one
for me and then um Julia Louis-Dreyfus
um yeah Seinfeld was big
um I had a bunch of male role models too
I thought um
I mean Will Ferrell was always like a
home run for me
um Bill Murray all Bill Murray stuff I
loved do you remember like early comedic
stuff you watched that you liked the
best like when you were yeah I mean so I
would go to my grandma's house every
Saturday night we would watch the entire
lineup The Golden Girls and the 227.
oh yeah
um that yeah those were those were big
that and Saturday night like my whole
family would watch that and I always
thought that was really good I liked
that they were just like balls out like
not trying to like be cute because back
then it was like everybody was watching
Three's Company and like stuff where
like the girls were just like pretty and
dumb and my mom was like you're not
watching Three's Company I've got a
specific question for Caitlyn here which
is from Vanessa Ramirez uh do you often
break bones because of carrying the
weight of being the best actor on sunny
that's not so much a question
um
Vanessa you're hired I like it so much
um no but Rob did make me get a bone
density test at one point because he had
had enough at what point in your life
did you get that oh yeah recently within
the last year well uh recently no it no
no it was like a bone density test yeah
that was within the last year no you had
broken you have broken so many bones
since since I've met you I know but it
wasn't within we've been married for a
very long time wasn't it was I know
which doctor did it and it was the one
at our old house it was at least five
years ago well it's time for another one
thank you Charlie my bones are dense as
hell zero problems it's just I I don't
know
she came back so proud of this
information I was like you realize that
that's that's worse that's even more
[__] up just means bones you've broken
and the fact that they are 10 right I
think that we don't got enough padding
and I'm gonna make it yeah
yeah how many bones of ten bones you
have not Rob's broken zero bones in his
life
in my life yeah so nuns once we've met
no bones your whole life no no how many
votes have you broken uh none
I'm not bragging that's pretty normal
when I uh was pregnant with our first
kid
um
because I'd broken my tailbone twice at
that point and it had healed weird
Strangely I guess she was like oh yeah I
don't know I can see your tailbone's
like kind of curved in she's like it'll
most likely break when the baby's on his
way out but it's not a big deal I'm like
no no no no no it is are you gonna
probably shatter the pieces when a baby
comes at you but the baby will be fine
you'll be fine you'll be fine you're
gonna blast your tailbone off your ass
but you you don't worry about it yeah
well you know what
it all worked out my tailbone did not
break when the baby came out just in
case there were any follow-up questions
when did it break broke a number of
times yeah and after all right take it
easy was one of those with the scooter
and the sweetie gets audited episode
right no I think I just crashed the bike
into this into the set I didn't get hurt
though yeah greatest throws to titles
ever is you in that helmet
I made all the contacts I pushed that
little monkey out and now I'm going to
be claiming him as a dependent and
getting tax breaks for the next 18 years
so you talk about a scheme how's that
for a long-term scheme [__] uh you
guys all better eat a dick cause sweet D
beat the system
[Music]
[Laughter]
yeah that was a good one
um it was a funny helmet made my head
look dumb yeah it was a good comedy yeah
I liked it
um okay uh if you could choose an actor
or actress to guest star on Sunny who
would it be can I bring Betty White back
from the dead because that would be so
nice wouldn't it be good
um but you did meet her and when she was
alive I did well yes yes I did a um like
Hollywood
reporter round table or something with
her um I told her how much I loved her
yeah we would write her little notes and
drop them off at her house she lived on
our street she lived on our street yeah
yeah we would drop off like a little
baskets we know she loved animals so we
would
um she said something funny about how
she she doesn't want to see pictures of
our kids but she wants to see so we we
dropped it was before like right when
everybody went into lockdown we wrote a
note just telling her how much we loved
her and what she meant to us growing up
and we weren't like crazy stalkers we
just had moved in recently we're crazy
neighbors
so we don't live somewhere else
we know where you live
um and I said you know we had two little
boys and two dogs and we you know walk
them on the street all the time so let
us know if you need anything because
we're you know I'm going to the grocery
store or whatever
um and left our phone numbers and she
called me one day my phone rang it was
this tiny little voice and she said
hello is this Caitlyn or Rob
I said it was Caitlin and she said um
she thanked us for the stuff and she she
said
um we do me a favor and hug your little
boys for me and I said of course thank
you and she said can you actually do
something that's even more important
than that for me and I said yes whatever
she said can you pet your dogs for me I
was like an animal lovers still got it
still got it yeah I love her that would
be like a moment I don't know if you do
this but sometimes I think back to like
if I could get in a time machine and go
back to myself when I was little and be
like hey here's something that's going
to happen to you one day like while
you're watching Golden Girls oh God that
would have blown my mind yeah you
wouldn't be able to connect those dots
like what do you mean I'm gonna meet I'm
gonna meet the characters she's not
she's not real she's on TV I'm going to
be in that house there on the TV yeah
all right uh who would win in a fight
Poppins or special agent Jack Bauer
yeah
ruthless yeah I mean yes it could be
like a draw because like Pockets
but if but
special agent Jack Bauer would pop that
other eye out of that pop and socket
yeah
[Music]
yeah I think so I think so the cat's
gonna win although yeah didn't he get
blown to safety he had blown to safety
yeah he's fine the cat's gonna be just
fine yeah one in the pool of gasoline
um there's a couple questions Charlie
about your shirts on the show
specifically the San Juan Islands one
and some Maroon wrestling shirt you have
that is like people
wrestling shirt I think
well did you bring any of those no I
think those were just like you know the
the Wardrobe Department says okay my
character probably shops at a thrift
store and goes and or Goodwill or or
find shirts on the street I don't know
and like you know and goes and gets a
few things and there's no particular
relation to it's really sorry for the
answer I was just um in a wardrobe
fitting before this and every year our
costume designer tells me the exact same
story which is she's so excited that she
gets to shop for me because she actually
gets to go shopping and get stuff and
then every year she's like Charlie I
just I try and get him I want to get him
some new stuff but every year he's just
like nah I just want to wear I just want
to wear the same stuff we don't need new
shirts we've got those shirts I'm like
yeah because does that make no sense for
my character yeah yeah like of course
Denison D would want new stuff you know
I wear the same pants every single
episode and we should talk to Sabrina um
you should maybe one day for the for the
podcast because those same shoes you've
had resold like yeah 15 times right yep
that's right those boots I liked the
episode where you put on the Charlie
sleeping costume though where you were
wearing the long jumps and like the
t-shirts
yeah yeah that was that was fun to see
you wear his outfits and do the cat food
thing that was really fun that's a good
one it is comfortable now that was my
shirt the horse shirt a couple of the
things the Army jacket
the horse shirt and the Vans with the
pink bottoms and I think the striped
jacket with red stripes were just and
the McGregor sweatshirt it was basically
just really that's your whole wardrobe
yeah it was just like how I was dressing
in 2005. yeah totally you know or four
or three or whatever we started shooting
it and uh
you know now I like I can't wear like an
army coat somewhere I'll feel like an
idiot there's a fan that is asking if
there are any Caitlyn Justice stories
like Rob Justice I don't think you're as
concerned with Justice as Rob are you
yeah have you have you enacted any
justice demanded any justice lately
I get kind of justicey sometimes yeah it
depends I don't like
mine's when the kids aren't in the car I
don't like when uh oh something just
happens I feel like I was driving
oh
yeah involved an old woman hold on she
had a handicapped thing placard and she
was like laying on her horn at me
because I had merged
I was like
I rolled down my window and I was like
no he's wagging my finger no no at her
like that because I wasn't gonna flip
her off because I felt rude she was old
I don't know if I like run in and like
you didn't think about jumping yeah
using bats from the bathroom let's get
into your psyche though when you've been
with your husband and he snapped into
Justice mode yeah
what's going on with you are you like oh
sweet my husband's stabbing Injustice
are you like oh dear God no no no don't
go out yeah what
there have been a couple of times
one that we don't one that involved a
physical altercation that I was yeah the
physical alterations one moment of
Justice where you're like thank you that
was sweet well we're recording and I I
was married in the early days we were
dating and I was uh yeah it was I was
there was an actual assault there was
yeah we were we were under attack Rob
took care of business and I was like
and we I it was not something I started
no and he wasn't something you started
and also there's a certain there's a
certain level sometimes when he I like
when he uses his words you know I mean I
like when he has like a a verbal
altercation and like explains why he's
right and they're wrong and then he's
like okay great and then like he feels
good about it and then it has a button
on the end of it and then I'm like okay
we can go oh as opposed to the physical
author there's always opposed to them I
didn't love the like the in and out
hopping out you were not there for that
no I wasn't I didn't like that story
that's fair your children were involved
right I wasn't there to protect them
maybe that's why I don't like that story
and I did come in and start and I led
with I think I did something very good
that was stupid yeah and yet I wanted to
get and I got some insight and I learned
I learned some things I like to think
that some of the Creeps and listeners
learn something he gets hot real fast
sometimes my thing is I just wish he
would take like think about it for a
second think about who's listening and
maybe what the consequences are and then
if he still feels like it's time to jump
in then go for it but usually if he
would just think about it a little bit
it's probably worth it to just let it go
and move on the man in the Rolls Royce
is trying to get his cheeseburgers
before me let me think about this one
it's irritating it's irritating it's
irritating but women are emotional
but we're the ones yes I wouldn't say
I'm emotional I'd say I'm quick to rage
quick to rage yeah I don't think I'm
quick to range
hmm you can be quick to rage sometimes
yeah
I'm scared people have to watch some
videos
very clear to everybody because there's
nothing sadder than a 40 how old am I 45
year old man looking to get into
physical altercations that has not
happened to get into effect and the last
time that happened was almost 20. no
yeah we were in our yeah you don't run
as hot as you used to like when we were
younger things yeah you don't have quite
the testosterone that used to be
coursing for you
it's very high on this printout it was
in red
it was listen I can't she feeds me steak
[Music]
all right that's awesome you know what I
mean I'm gonna test you like Jose
Canseco man this is actually Summers
were very high
[Music]
this might feed into this next question
which is just simply why Rob oh yeah oh
good question
after all right after all that oh sorry
that's not for you it's for replica
yeah there's a comma I'm so sorry oh man
you skipped it
um yeah I didn't really think twice
about him and the audition just thought
everybody was funny and nice very cute
yeah you're really cute
yeah and cute
um then we started working and he just
was so good at his job
um and had never done this job before
and I had been on shows before and
recognized how hard it was to run a show
usually it was like adult men running
shows
um I would like to say or women but I
don't think that I knew any female
showrooms
no
um but he just was very in charge but
also very kind and very funny and just
knew what he wanted and very
level-headed and was just a very good
boss and was and I just was very
attracted to that I appreciate that you
said I was level-headed because now I
would like for the audience to to not
believe that I if you talk to any of our
crew your employees they will talk about
how you are the best boss they've ever
had that is very true it I hear it all
the time sometimes people take me aside
to tell me that you're the best boss
that they've ever had that's nice for
you which is a horrific waste of my time
because I'd say it's nice for you to
hear it you know just so you can have a
little bit of perspective I I see it
you're out there and you're looking
around at some of the other guys I'm
looking around I know you are yeah
all the emails
we might as well complete the uh
yeah I don't think it's I don't think
anybody would need to hear me explain
why I think based on it took me a while
though I really had to work at you you
did yeah yeah she personally put it out
there yeah I was I was um I was confused
as to why I wasn't getting the response
that I was expecting it was confusing to
me I was a professional I recognized the
power Dynamic she's like I'm really I
said this is inappropriate yeah
you should thank me for this wake up
buddy yeah yeah yeah I I thought wow
this is uh
[Music]
yeah it just uh just just made me burn
brighter yeah now we're hearing all
sorts of stories about office
environments in Hollywood yeah people
getting fired where people uh are just
burning real hot real hot in those
casting room couches and whatnot and I I
wanted to make sure I was not a part of
that I was already cast
[Laughter]
you were in a position of power
not just to be clear no sexual
harassment falling in love with someone
that you work with even if you're their
boss and they're below you sexual
harassment would come in if either of
you said no and then the other one like
tormented you at work
is exactly what happened that's not well
okay I did I not rebuff your advances
it's only harassment if it doesn't lead
to marriage and children that's right
Fair let's just leave it but there was a
period of time
very clearly said uh both both verbally
and with my um what's that called
um uh non-verbal I was both verbal and
not I guess
no I think it's a purple body language
this is a metaphor I don't know what's
he talking about I said um we definitely
definitely made out after a fox party
one time and it would there was not
there was no no being thrown around that
was the first time
not not a one the first time that's why
I was like oh okay well this is
reciprocal and then you're like oh
you've got a boyfriend
that I should probably address she can
Meg can cut this but I want my friends
to know the truth you yeah you yeah
Advanced on me not a number of times
at Charlie's house you're large it
happened
we were at Charlie's house
yeah I brought my friend from Oregon
over we were playing uh board games you
were living at my play season one or we
were just there hanging out I can't
remember exactly what it was but you're
out by then yeah finally you got me out
of there you know what it was it's that
um I really I was really feeling like oh
I'm like falling in love with this
person and I was trying not to and I was
very professional at work and then the
problem was then we'd find ourselves at
uh events there would be alcohol you'd
make me nervous so I would drink because
then I felt a little better and then I'd
act like a fool and then I would wake up
and beat myself up
for a very long time
um yeah and then and then then the whole
thing would happen again that went on
for a while and then and then I saw I
stopped I got the message I stopped and
then Charlie's wedding happened
at a certain point my New Orleans you
know you know what are you gonna do yeah
at a certain point you can only be
respectful for so respectful of the
situation for so long you have a woman
this beautiful this talented very kind
um
when did the candle go out
as have you making anybody out there the
creeps delicious they know that the
candle goes out all the time and then
you gotta relight it and then it goes
out then you got to relight it marriage
is hard I think people look at us maybe
and they're like oh that seems like a
functional relationship and it is most
of the time but then it's not and we've
had really Rocky times yeah nobody has a
like a smooth fun that's not but we only
see the Instagram version of things yes
and we we have had a very difficult
rocky road from time to time and we
always come back I think it was that
difficulties
no yeah they're they're definitely been
ups and downs but the thing is
um we're we're good friends and we I
feel like we respect each other yeah
that's good that's what you need all
right all right it's not a marriage uh
or a therapy podcast yeah yeah that's
right speaking of overcoming challenges
here's a question what was the most
challenging episode to make from start
to finish whoa uh that's a good question
I mean look it's hard to say because I
don't write all the music and whatnot
like these guys do so the amount of
effort and energy and time that goes
into writing those songs for say
nightman coming to say it was nightmare
that was like rehearsals and or even the
um where the gang turns black yeah but
like it's challenging like maybe like
like
difficulty like the underwater stuff was
difficult yeah yeah yeah you know when
the game goes to hell that's saying yeah
hello baby
Chris
I love you whatever
I just remember I was I'm not a water
person and that was terrifying and then
went and it was the last shot I know it
was last shot because Danny was like I'm
done
um it was time for my time to go up and
I went and kicked up as fast as I could
but I was wearing heels and I kicked
Danny with my heel on the top of his
head yeah and then he came up and just
got right out of the water went right to
his trailer and went home I'm done I was
like
yeah you know what's interesting I will
say that
um just talking about that story from
the other day the writing process is by
far the is the hardest and it takes the
most out of us
um I think production is just really
really mostly a ton of fun fun I don't
know that there are episodes so in terms
of like what was the hardest episode to
to make that's really something that we
would do our style of making something
isn't like so technically precise that
we're like it took us forever to nail
that one even the Charlie work one which
was a water like yeah I don't know like
shackman had really choreographed it so
well and Adam's Kalina on the camera got
it so well I'd memorize the stuff so I
was good and it kind of we didn't
rehearsed it five takes and maybe take
two is the one like
so like one episode that people don't
realize that was not a ton of fun to
shoot and I remember this being the case
because I remember how fun it was to
write it came together very very quickly
to break and write and I remember
reading it and we were like oh we're
gonna have so much fun shooting this and
then it was absolutely miserable
shooting it was the Charlie macdennis
episode you know that's funny I I was
thinking that I remember I totally
remember like in that room I guess yeah
or was it one Florida one third on the
third floor yeah yeah and then like just
the fun of like coming up with like uh
flip a coin at the end but yeah what was
it it was a continuity thing right like
it was it was like uh yes and because we
were all in every shot of every scene
and we were screaming through screaming
screaming that's what it was yeah it was
like and the what's the what's that war
date oh the Maori award yeah yeah which
actually when you're like really doing
it it's so funny to happen if you don't
grow up doing that as a part of your
culture
I never thought about that because you
yeah obviously you all are in every
single scene yes so much so that when we
were finished shooting it I I was like
oh that sucked like that's gonna be bad
because it usually if we're not having
fun with it it's gonna not be great and
then we saw it in post and we were like
oh yeah
gentlemen
suck my dick
[Music]
[Applause]
what about the one where you were
covered with blood from Heaven I
remember that day for you and I'm
feeling so bad that was one of my
hardest days that ended in in tears yeah
it just I definitely have a video from
that from that day I have a video from
that day that I shot on on a flip phone
and that was so long ago right and it
was a video of you and you and you just
kept saying I don't like it I don't like
it I don't like it I'm not having fun
and I was just like funny because I
gotta put this because I think she's I'm
not sure if she's joking or not you're
like I'm not joking I don't like it I
don't like it I'm not I'm not and
they're like okay Caitlyn you know get
down on the blood and you're like I
don't like it I don't like it I don't
like it I don't want to do it but I just
need everyone to know I don't like it I
gotta find that and also this was late
at night and I'd been in that blood all
day I haven't been in that blood for
hours yeah and the thing is it's not
just sticky and gross it starts to dry
and every move you make your hair is
being ripped out of your body so whether
it's your arm or God forbid I looked
down like all the hairs ripping out of
the back of my neck and then then I had
to lay it down and I'm sure they brushed
the ground but I had like pebbles and
rocks stuck all over my body it just was
it just was very un I mean I'm not gonna
complain
hey guys it's a brand new year and
having 2022 officially in the books
means one thing that'll take at least a
month of writing 22 on dates before your
brain switches to writing 23 right
forever no no that it is now 23 and
we're officially in the Jordan year it's
not quite where I was going no
um I was going to say that having 2022
in the books means your books are in the
books and now you have to pay taxes on
them but have you ever thought about
just not doing your taxes you can go to
jail for that you would go to jail for
that yeah well no I mean someone needs
to do them but that someone doesn't need
to be you with Turbo Tax you don't have
to do your taxes you can meet with an
expert who will do them for you that's
right they'll do your taxes start to
finish guaranteeing they're done right
so you can relax because there's almost
no better feeling than being done with
taxes I can only think of a handful of
things like winning your sixth ring
that's a reference to Michael Jordan
yeah okay you're still on the Jordan
yeah yeah so come on to Turbo Tax and
don't do your taxes visit turbotax.com
to learn more Intuit Turbo Tax full
service products only video meeting
while expert does your taxes required so
you guarantee details at turbotax.com
guaranteeds
this show is sponsored by betterhelp
betterhelp is an online therapy service
where licensed professionals can help
you tackle issues you may be dealing
with or just help you feel your best in
general when do you guys feel your best
when do your minds clear and let you
just live in the moment like you've just
had a great therapy session the moment I
arrive on a golf course not while you're
actually golfing well I never know how
the golfing is going to go so I don't
maybe I'll assume my best while playing
but when I get there a lot of hope you
might need a therapy session for the
golf that's right I might need to fire
up better help on the links Meg you've
used betterhelp have you ever used it on
a golf course yeah I've never actually
used it on a golf course but better help
was great for me in the sense of working
through an issue with someone I felt
like you know understood it guys today a
therapists that would understand my golf
balls like if I missed a putt would they
be like you know it doesn't reflect on
you as a person I'm gonna go out on a
limb and say yes someone in their vast
directory of experts has heard golf
gripes before okay great done uh I've
never been more excited to to have a bad
run of golf you know sure sure look if
you want to live a more empowered life
therapy can get you there visit
betterhelp.com sunny today to get 10 off
your first month that's better help
h-e-l-p.com slash Sunny
[Music]
we could counter this with what episode
do you have the best memories from which
is another question that people have any
ones you remember being super fun
I mean that's the Water Park episode was
so fun yeah so fun because each each
storyline was was separate so we had a
lot of time where we were either on
camera a lot of time
um behind the monitors but also
everything that we shot inside that the
uh the tubes which was the most fun to
shoot because we got to go today
it was my birthday I got so drunk the
night before I was so hungover we have a
video of that too where are you guys
recording me we got into one of those um
gondolas and we were going up to the top
of the mountain and I was like I was
like I'm gonna throw up
everybody's laughing at me because he
doesn't drink that but he never gets
that drunk and he's never that hung over
who's established on the podcast that he
drinks all the time I drink all the time
but I never get it doesn't get that
drunk or it certainly doesn't yeah and I
was like oh my God I'm definitely gonna
throw up and of course my friends
are all laughing at me as they should as
they should and we're going up the
gondola and yeah maybe it was you
recording and you're like how's it going
man I'm like I'm definitely gonna puke
and we have you couldn't like open the
window I guess so I was like if I throw
up I'm gonna throw up all over you know
everybody here oh that would make me go
I don't know altitude we went up that
day it was his birthday
and then woke up the next morning and
had to shoot and the altitude snuck up
on you yeah that's also on shootings
like Camp you know where you're like oh
like the work is done now we get to sort
of play and be funny and we're in a cool
place and uh
yeah it's a good Adventure it's like
being at a destination wedding or out of
town wedding where you're like in a fun
place together yeah and you always make
the classic mistake of going too hard
the first night because you're so
excited about it yeah I think I think
that ski trip was the last time I was
sick from alcohol yeah I think that was
oh screw you man that's crazy really I
think so and that was like seven years
ago but oh no
oh no no oh no no no all your friends my
friends
stayed with us oh boy so oh sometimes I
truly believe like I can Dr I can drink
I drink you know I'm not bragging about
it but like I can drink a ton of alcohol
and still be okay then you hang out with
those kind of guys like that Philly crew
and their wives yes and they can drink
for days but a lot of them I will say
are also like six three yeah two twenty
like they're Big Fellas they're huge and
I try to keep up with them and that is
kicked you like a little pet or
something in high school like those guys
are giants yeah they're huge yeah
they're huge they went all golfing and
then rolled into your house oh they
rolled into our house and the tallest
one Mike Gallagher came in first yeah
and I was like hey how was it and he
came over to me and he bent down
and they all kissed me on the cheek he
like came in for this kiss and it kind
of came in at a weird angle and guy he
got my neck and he was kissing my neck
and he goes I gotta warn you those guys
are so drunk
you're the sober representative you
don't know they sent you in yeah yeah
I had to drive
uh nobody tries
for the whole weekend we went to an
Eagles game that in LA Coliseum uh at
night it was a night game so yeah isn't
this what gave you ulcers yeah well so
yeah that when I woke up the day after
that it was three days of straight
drinking and I was like I I can't I
don't I'm done I'm done I'm gonna
balance something between that and and
being in the office staring out the
windows in the space because you've
blasted your brains of the work like
isn't that just like a middle ground
yeah
[Laughter]
I'm never down for very long yeah just
the other night that's a little scary it
was scary because I'm very rarely that's
right and then I woke up in the morning
at like 5 30 you were out of bed and I
was like oh no also he didn't sleep but
then when I saw you in the morning you
were you were you were back yeah I feel
like it's always just the feeling of
like oh it's never going to come
together we're never going to get it
we're a million miles away and then
always with story breaking and stuff it
just changes like you find one little
thing and then all of a sudden you love
it your confidence shoots up about it
every year I remind him that every year
he does this at this time during this
particular process it's because you guys
care so much and I'm as the non-writer
in the room I'm incredibly grateful that
you bend over backwards and feel that
way about it because it's what makes you
keep at it until it's at its best
somebody has asked if we can just we can
explain what we mean when we say
something is Broad oh okay I just said
that on the podcast before that it felt
a little too broad and so they've asked
if you can clarify with it I guess
that's just a way of saying a joke is uh
just beyond believable right so that
whatever the joke is either the reality
of the event that's happening or the
reality of the person uh caring about
what it is that they're doing is just
pass
what we think we can get away with so
acting can be broad too when someone's
doing something that's a little like you
can be big but then if there's something
that for whatever reason makes you cross
over into like cartoon character land
then it's broad don't you think it's
just the belief of like the intention
right so you're like oh I believe
behaving this way
is either a real human reaction or
really what they want but like some
people like
can get away with it like like uh well
Pharaoh can do something gigantic yeah
and you're like you absolutely 100
believe his character and Elf or
whatever yeah is gonna behave like that
every step of the way like you've
obviously done lots of things on the
show like you being covered in blood
from head to toe could be really broad
but because you're so miserable your
character is so miserable in that
situation because we understand that you
want to be in this movie so badly that
you would like do this thing and I'm
willing to go to this but you're willing
and then you're a dead body that's
always like trying to get your face in
the shot and stuff like you just buy
that motivation so the broadness of
being covered head to toe like yeah
abroad might not always necessarily be a
bad thing it just depends on your taste
yeah it's an imaginary subjective line
right because yeah you know one of the
things we always strive for in the show
um I I think we don't always hit this
Mark but that the characters themselves
can do all sorts of crazy things we've
talked about this in the podcast before
but it's it bears eating as long as they
believe as long as we believe that the
characters believe that what they're
doing is going to get them what they
want then we can buy it and then in
terms of the world itself we try not to
populate
the normal world or the real world with
silly broad ideas yeah every once in a
while we'll have mcpoils or Artemis or
or you know the moms and we'll populate
our characters that way but but we still
live in the real world and once we get
outside of that that's when things start
to get a little wacky you know it kind
of is like we always have a grounded
person for the heightened person and you
know when we get into scenes with our
moms or Uncle Jack or whoever we become
that we become that it shifts and
suddenly we're like oh come on man you
know I'm reacting to someone in a way
and then other times it's us against
like someone who works at a bank or
something I wonder if traditionally the
word Broad in our business would mean if
it had something as broad appeal it
means that it appeals to a wide audience
I wonder if people specifically in
comedy took that and then used it as a
pejorative meaning if you can appeal to
a broad audience then you're not being
specific and nuanced and it's not
targeted and then it's comedy quote
unquote for everybody which is
impossible
you know what I mean whereas like Studio
Executives would say broad appeal is
actually a good thing you have as many
people enjoying your thing as possible
and I could see comedians being like
[__] that yeah maybe I mean but isn't
like the most universal comedy like
slapstick comedy physical comedy is like
because you don't need language for it
everybody can watch a Charlie Chaplin
movie and like understand what's going
on
um but those tend to be like broad but
then like there is something there's a
reason why it appeals to so many people
because there's something Primal and
Universal about watching that thing and
immediately understanding why it's funny
yeah so right but you wouldn't talk
about a Charlie Chaplin movie if you
were to say it's broad it wouldn't be in
a negative light right sometimes there's
a broad in it
that's best
[Music]
here's one which I would like to know um
Caitlyn what's your favorite swear word
um I like stuff like um
I like a
favorite swear word Dee's favorite word
would be God God damn it the way you
deliver it is arguably the best of any
of the characters I try to mix it up
um I don't know I like when people
call people like a buffoon or some
something like silly is funnier to me
than like a swear word but I'm also
living in a household of like pre-teens
who think that swearing is really fun
and I'm just finding it annoying yeah
it's just like whenever they're learning
that
yeah like you guys it's not funny okay
like when you swear all the time it's
not necessarily funny I like how you
guys bought this house
well Caitlin thank you for coming in
yeah thanks for uh coming in and for
having me helping us get some funnies
out and uh can't wait to start shooting
with you too it'll be very exciting next
Wednesday stuff coming up oh by the time
this podcast come out comes out Monday
yeah yeah on Monday it'll be two more
days until shooting it's exciting very
excited
[Music]